the first shipments of grain to avert a
looming global food crisis are expected
to leave ukraine this week despite the
war raging around its ports under united
nations brokered agreement with russia a
ukrainian minister says that shipments
of wheat corn and sunflower oil will
leave their black sea ports through the
newly negotiated safe channels within
days
the port in china mosque will be the
first one then odessa then port
overall in two weeks we'll be
technically ready to export out of all
the terminals of above mentioned ports
that is despite a russian strike on the
port of odessa on saturday russia's
foreign minister says there are no
barriers to the grain deliveries but
adds a warning yesterday
there's nothing in the obligation that
russia took including within the
framework of the agreement signed on
july 22nd in istanbul which prohibit us
from continuing the special military
operation destroying military
infrastructure and other military
targets
the saturday strike in odessa makes
clear that includes targets in the ports
it also includes ammunition depots the
russian military said on monday that it
struck one in ukraine's central kamal
nitsky region that housed u.s supplied
highmars rocket systems
ukraine's military says those precision
multi-launch rocket systems have changed
the balance in the war allowing them to
destroy 50 russian ammunition depots
since they arrived and ukraine is asking
for more to break through the russian
line
after all that our people have gone
through after all that we have learned
over the centuries ukrainians will never
give up their independence
both the russian and the ukrainian
strikes were reported in western ukraine
far from the front lines leaving no safe
haven in the country right now
as ukrainian forces push toward her son
in the south foreign fighters continue
to battle alongside ukrainian troops on
the eastern front near harkeef
for every every one of our boys that's
killed we have to avenge them
as the ports plan to resume grain
exports on the front lines the war of
attrition continues
john hendren al jazeera